esta población de mi calor está a
135 kilómetros al este violencia y a
pesar de ser una ciudad bastante grande
con más de 400 mil habitantes se ha
convertido en ese escudo que protege a
odessa de la invasión rusa de las tropas
cruza se encuentra más o menos a 30 km
tanto al sur al este y al norte de la
ciudad la única puerta abierta que queda
es hacia odessa y dicen que en el
momento en que esta ciudad caiga pues ya
quedaría todo abierto para que las
tropas entren por la vía terrestre y
tienen a las embarcaciones frente a la
ciudad nos encontramos en uno de los
lugares más tristes de esta guerra que
es la morgue de la ciudad que ha
terminado convertida en un frente de
batalla con ataques tanto aéreos como
con artillería y con cohetes que han
muerto muchísima gente no solamente
militares sino civiles nos acabamos de
encontrar con una familia por ejemplo
el padre había muerto en un ataque aéreo
a una escuela y nos dice también los
forenses que mueren muchísimos niños